bonsoir Tamara bonsoir Patrice je vais
essayer quand il dit je ne veux pas
détruire l'Ukraine est-ce que c'est une
tentative pour baisser le ton un peu je
ne pense pas je pense que ça s'inscrit
dans ce discours qu'il donne qu'il va en
russe et aussi à son à son public là il
est au Kazakhstan donc avec ces
homologues de l'Asie centrale kazakhsan
qui résistant
Ouzbékistan donc des alliés encore de
Vladimir Poutine surtout économique et
donc ça s'inscrit dans ce discours que
la Russie n'est pas en mode attaque elle
est en mode défensive rappelez-vous on
présente encore cette guerre ce conflit
comme une opération spéciale nécessaire
pour protéger les intérêts de la Russie
donc on le fait d'entendre Vladimir
Poutine aujourd'hui dire très clairement
notre but n'est pas de la détruire c'est
dans sa logique et vous allez l'entendre
dans l'extrait qu'on va vous présenter
c'est qu'il est en mode défensive et
c'était ses attaques multiples vraiment
inégalé depuis le début de la guerre les
grandes villes du crâne cette semaine
c'était en réponse direct à cette
attaque du pont de l'acrymique qui est
un symbole hyper important pour la
puissance russe on peut écouter Vladimir
Poutine un extrait de sa conférence de
presse
[Musique]
provoqué
pour l'instant il y aura pas d'autres
attaques violentes comme ça mais pour la
suite on le sait pas autrement dit si
vous osez encore nous attaquer mais on
va répondre et on n'hésitera pas de le
faire bon il a dit par ailleurs dans ce
point de presse il a dit la mobilisation
générale ne sera pas élargie on a les
hommes qui font or ça correspond pas
tout à fait disons-le à la réalité non
d'abord il le dit au Kazakhstan où il y
a écouté ça Patrice plus de 200 000
hommes russes qui se sont exilés en
moins d'un mois donc là aussi il y avait
un public important
et donc ce qu'il a dit aujourd'hui
Vladimir Poutine c'est que la Russie la
l'armée russe avait recruté jusqu'à
maintenant depuis un mois 220 000 hommes
donc il en manque à peu près 80 000 et
que quand à lui les efforts de
recrutement donc de cette mobilisation
qui est partielle seront terminées d'ici
deux semaines mais regardez les vidéos
qu'on vous a préparé ça c'est un
échantillon de ce qu'on retrouve sur les
médias sociaux plusieurs comptes
vérifier aujourd'hui des jeunes hommes
et ça c'est à Moscou là en plein
centre-ville qu'on attend à l'extérieur
ou en bas de leur appartement qu'on
attend à la sortie du métro et qu'on
recrute même s'il ne correspondent pas
nécessairement au profil des gens qu'il
faut recruter écouter un extrait je
pense qu'on voit une arrestation
[Musique]
adore de toute évidence des jeunes qui
n'ont pas pris la fuite dont on n'a pas
tout le contexte mais c'est sain là
Patrice se répète de villes en ville au
moment où de la même de certaines
autorités c'est le chaos cette
mobilisation et non seulement la
pratique de mobiliser les hommes et les
erreurs flagrantes qui ont été faites
parce qu'on recrute des gens qui n'ont
pas le profil démobilisés mais aussi
avec l'équipement et ce qu'on leur donne
pour aller au front il y a des
témoignages qui qui nous arrivent de
certaines de certaines lignes de front
où les soldats témoignent à la caméra
ouvertement on manque de bouffe on
manque d'équipements on a aucun ordre on
a eu deux semaines d'entraînement
plusieurs recrutés qui sont arrivés il y
a même pas une semaine au front sont
morts photos à l'appui donc ça c'est
c'est très difficile pour Vladimir
Poutine cette question de mobilisation
il avait intérêt aujourd'hui du moins à
signaler que ça va prendre fin mais
est-ce que c'est vrai
le temps nous le dira et en rapidement
en terminant je disais est-ce que c'est
un signe d'apaisement pas vraiment parce
qu'il le répète que ce conflit pourrait
dégénéré en catastrophe mondiale oui
mais ça il faut faire attention il
répondait spécifiquement à l'OTAN le
temps est plusieurs alliés de l'Ukraine
cette semaine qui ont d'ici la Russie
parce que ça c'est une des grandes
crêtes des grandes craintes si la Russie
a recours à des armes tactiques donc oui
des armes nucléaires mais peut-être plus
petites c'est quand même la ligne rouge
les réactions de le temps vont être
sévères et là on parle pas de sanctions
mais on parle d'une réponse physique
alors la réponse à ça à Vladimir Poutine
c'est réfléchissez bien et ça ça
s'adresse à le temps s'il y a un contact
direct entre les forces de l'OTAN et
l'armée russe et ça c'est la crainte
depuis le tout début Patrice on se
dirige vers un conflit qui serait
potentiellement catastrophique pour la
planète on en est pas là et je vous
dirais même que les
conservateur et les renseignements
américains européens ne voient pas en ce
moment en tout cas elle voit une menace
d'une crise nucléaire assez faible pour
le moment on va espérer que ça reste
comme ça Tamara le teresco merci
beaucoup je vous en prie au revoir
[Musique]